all right are you ready for the rodeo
showdown the world's best
bull riders are back here in town for
pbr that's right they're taking on the
bucking
bulls starting tonight at the mgm hector
mejia has been live this morning
annoying the bulls relentlessly
with a look at what fans can expect all
weekend long hector good morning to you
not what you want to do doing that hey
there good morning guys so yeah this is
all happening at the mtm
grand garden arena and this sets the
stage for what's to come in november
that is the world championship happening
here in town again
at t-mobile arena and with us with us
this morning
see with us this morning we have dakota
to talk to us about
all right what's right next to you right
here so i'm a little intimidated here
being next to the bulls
as you can tell this is a world finalist
buck and gold bucking for cash
and uh he's definitely one of the top
bovine athletes we have here in las
vegas tell us what are you competing
this weekend
i'm going gonna be competing tonight on
uh a different bull
but uh hopefully in the championship
round i end up matching up with him
bands are back what are you looking
forward to the most i'm looking forward
to everybody
screaming their heads off when i'm 95
points
and what goes through your mind when
you're on a ball
um watch out to stay safe
no just to stay on stay in the middle
and get the eight seconds
gotcha thank you very much for joining
us also joining us this morning we have
michaela
and cheyenne michaela you're competing
this weekend
good morning to you and who do we have
here this is my daughter cheyenne
she's four months old so yes we got up
early but
so far we're pleasant sorry to wake her
up this morning
that's okay nellis what are you
competing in and tell us about the
the bill pickett invitational yes so i'm
gonna be competing in the barrel race
sunday
and the bill pick is partnering with the
pbr
so we get to compete sunday afternoon
how do you train for something like this
um it's just
every day you ride and work horses and
try to keep them in shape and
last year um was kind of hard with the
coveted
stuff and a lot of stuff was cancelled
but
we're looking forward to events like
this this year and you were telling me
earlier that it's in your blood how long
have you been a part of this for
um so my dad had me on a horse when i
was three days old
and so i've been around rodeo my whole
life and it's like cheyenne
yes and she's well on her way so yeah
how old is cheyenne she is four months
old we have been
going pretty much since she was born so
she has a lot of miles on that little
butt and she's nothing but smiles this
morning she is
she's pretty happy she's definitely a
morning baby as the
day goes on we get a little bit cranky
but she likes the mornings
so this worked good thank you for
joining us so it all starts tonight and
it's happening through the weekend
tonight saturday and sunday all
happening at the mgm grand garden arena
and just take a look this is bucking for
cash here we woke him up
early in the morning he's actually been
standing up all
you know for the last couple of hours or
so he's not even resting he's just uh
not letting his guard down as we're
right next to him this morning anyway
we'll be posting all of the details on
our website eightnewsnow.com for now
reporting live hector mejia
back to you guys hector the way that
little cheyenne is looking at you
that is the cutest thing with her little
giraffe
and now hector i enjoyed the adorable
to go from cheyenne to the adorable
child
to this enormous mean bowl you get both
extremes
all right thank you hector good to have
pbr back yeah it is